from software's new game is open-world
there will be significant RPG elements
its allegedly the largest project
today's and it's called Eldon ring Eldon
rings development started just as
development for Dark Souls 3 DLC ended
as of today that's more than 2 years of
development and while we don't have a
release date for this multi-platform
title I would put my money on early 2020
this is considering that from software
often launches new titles in March and
also that secular is likely to get DLC
later this year and unlike secular
Miyazaki states that Eldon Ring puts
more focus on RPG elements which I know
is gonna please all of us that means he
says a wide variety of weapons magic and
ways to engage enemies with the
strategies that suit you more variety
says Miyazaki even when compared to the
Dark Souls series and you want to know
why that's incredible because that kind
of diversity meshes really well with the
fact that this game is open-world for
the first time Miyazaki does say that
there are many definitions to the term
open world but that fromsoftware has
simply tried their hand at creating a
game with a large open field to play in
a world that yes still contains
intricately designed levels such as
multi-layered castles and such he says
and I can only assume that this means
we'll be able to tackle those areas in
whatever order we like which again could
be incredible because whenever I play
Dark Souls I tried a sequence break as
fast as possible I always try to deck
out my character with unique gear from
all over the game not just the gear
that's at the start of the game and from
an RPG point of view linear progression
has always held back souls to an extent
when you think about it however it
really does sound like Eldon Ring will
afford the player the opportunity to try
to any corner of the world from the get
go and get this Miyazaki says this is
without a doubt our biggest title yet in
terms of sheer volume and he says that
the scale of the world and the narrative
to accompany it matches that and he goes
on to say maybe as expected the game
will still include intense boss fights
character creation and perhaps most
importantly a focus on overcoming
challenges
it sounds like they haven't given in to
the people crying for an easy mode just
yet which is good news
after all the game is about the will or
the ambition of mankind says Miyazaki
and this alliance with the press release
that I received which stated that an
adventure awaits the brave and the
gallant all this wording really aligns
with the heroic visuals that you see in
the trailer there's this nobility of the
self in this trailer and that's in stark
contrast to a lot of Dark Souls visuals
for example which often emphasizes the
worthlessness of the self instead of the
nobility of the self and Misaki said
that they wanted to create a title
that's full of the things that they
weren't able to do in the Dark Souls
series and that includes breaking out
into a whole new mythos a body of
mythology that is written by george RR
martin and you can tell me as ik is this
huge fan of the guy he writes that
george provided incredible stimulus for
the team that george wrote characters
drama and mystical elements that would
go on to shape Elden rings presentation
so to me this sounds like george laid
the foundations and miyazaki and his
team built upon those foundations
and so we arrived finally at the trailer
let me point out some of the curious
aspects of it five arms spring from the
darkness arms that have these nobly
protrusions and an extra elbow almost as
if they're sort of curved outwards from
this character's own back they support
this crowned man or woman it's hard to
say as he or she raises a twitching
larger hand shift on to their own arm
this is likely seculars lost arm just
kidding this seems like a sort of dark
ritual one that sets a pretty horrific
tone for the game going forward I doubt
you could even imagine which commanded
the scars
life its fullest brains the Elden ring
says Miyazaki is the name given to a
mysterious concept that defines the
world itself so it's this cosmic
unimaginable force and what we see in
the trailer is its shattering presumably
at the hands of this blacksmith and I'm
willing to bet that he's a sort of
blacksmith deity which is a concept that
exists not only in Norse mythology not
only in Celtic mythology but even in
Dark Souls as well and this shattering
could also go on to explain the games
logo four rings of fire which are out of
sync with one another
speaking of which the word Eldon may not
simply mean old or ancient or elder but
it could be echoing the Old Norse term
elder meaning fire this could explain
the burning sky that we see in the scene
to follow
Oh
in this scene the Crimson haired woman
reattaches a sort of brass arm which is
either locked on with magnetic force or
magic because there is not much there to
attach to and it's a parallel to the
character in the first scene who is
grafting on an arm of flesh which may be
a significant parallel in the end on the
other hand of the woman though it
doesn't look that good she's sporting
blackened flesh and a sheen of rust that
is glinting in the sunlight also note
the parallel between the rust on her arm
and the cracking of the blacksmith's
it's almost as if they're all made of
some sort of stone and I assume there
are sort of divine entity immediately
after this
this warrior thrusts his spear into the
belly of his foe and the Alton ring
shatters right after this shattered
by someone or something
along with a dialogue about it being
shattered by someone or something I take
this to sort of mean that the blacksmith
probably isn't the only reason the ring
is being undone and with every blow that
the blacksmith strikes his own flesh
cracks so too does the flesh of this
ashen haired woman who appears to also
be holding the hilt of another
blacksmith hammer in this scene the two
aren't just connected with each other
they're also synced with the ring and
they're all shattering together the rest
of the cast are connected as well as we
fly along with this spear as if were
attached to it with a GoPro take note of
the fallen corpses in the background
they're the same fallen corpses which
are present in this scene with the
kneeling tusk helmed Knight it's very
likely that this was who speak I thrust
his spear into and you even see
something that could be the task
knight's sword in the background this
guy as well as crimson hair and I assume
this signifies a sort of shared faction
between these two characters
don't tell me you don't see it
[Music]
obviously the shattering of this ring
has implications for the entire cycle of
the world and I can only assume that our
playable created character will appear
after this crucial moment this is so
shattering that a new world order likely
has to be defined and since the theme of
the game is the ambition of man maybe
the gods have become vulnerable and it's
our time to shine or something like that
it sounds pretty familiar for from
software with one final strike the
blacksmith breaks the ring bringing it
raining down atop the two cracked beings
and a cracked logo appears as well so
all of this pretty much aligns with the
first set of leaks that we received
where we discussed the game by its
internal working title great Rudin it
was open-world it involves visiting
kingdoms and it does seem to be inspired
by Norse mythology in retrospect that
video is more worth checking out than I
anticipated it being and on the note of
Norse mythology we should devote some
time to the likely cultural inspirations
that are present in Elden ring as well
but you should bear in mind that unlike
some titles like god of war for example
from software rarely takes concepts in
their entirety instead they're more
inspired by these cultures and it often
feels like they build ideas outwards
from them so for example in this trailer
and in the lakes it's likely that
they're building off of Norse and Celtic
mythology z' while i was streaming the
announcement live on twitch a bunch of
people drew parallels to and i'm gonna
butcher the name but Nuada a god with an
arm of silver that was forged for him by
one of three gods of craftsmanship and
also Luke and
with a spear that always hits its mark
they are all of the Torah day done on
the tribe of the Gods these noble beings
are in opposition to the for more eons
supernatural beings that represents
darker powers and already it's possible
we see this same sort of contrast in the
trailer I'd also like to draw your
attention to this character who has a
helmet sporting too angelic wings this
is a popular visual for the Valkyrie of
Norse mythology Valkyrie will warrior
women who descended upon the battlefield
and judged the Fallen and if you were
deemed to have died bravely in battle
then the Valkyrie would take you to
Valhalla a Hall where you would dine and
eventually fight alongside Odin himself
there's more like the Celtic knot
imagery Norse hammers but for now it's
probably best to take these likely
inspirations with a grain of salt the
only thing we don't know at this point
is about the gameplay
sekito in my opinion set a new standard
for combat systems in these games and if
anything I desperately hope that they
took on some of these combat innovations
during development it's kind of hard to
go back to souls now anyway subscribe
and ring the bell so you can be the
first to learn about the gameplay
whenever it crops up and I'll see you
next time
you
[Music]